Mình đã tổng gặp a thông không, và tổng gặp lại hợp như những một thịt sinh đặt 3 người điểm đến từ bắt nền.
Tổ hợp bây con không, toán hợp xin hợp, có muốn thịt sinh đặt điểm từ nối, nhiều nhất trong các hồi sế tuyển.
Bây n đến từ thành phố chim mêng, một em đến từ đắt lắt, ở cơ tổ hợp còn lại không có thịt sinh đặt nước điểm từ nối.
Thủ khóa khóa không một, toán và tổng gặp, đặt 2 mình chính phẩm bệm năm điểm.
Thủ khóa khói điểm không một, toán ữ văn tính anh đã tham chính điểm.
Thủ khóa khói sế không không, nữ văn lịch sự địa liy, đặt 3 mình tán vài bệm làm điểm.
Các bạn đều là thi xinh của hãn nội.
Đáng chú ý thêu công của điểm thì, tôi nghĩa trong phụ thông năm năm kinh không trong nhà sau của bộ giữ vừa đạo cạo.
Năm nay, cả nước có bệnh nghiên tán chăm tán mười mốt bài thi đặt điểm người.
Dạm gần một nửa xói năm năm năm kinh không trong năm, hơn mười lắm nghiên bài chăm bài thi đặt điểm người.
Trong đó, toán là món có số lượng bài thi đặt điểm người, nhớ.
Bởi mỗi nghiên hai chăm lệ cá mạc thi đặt điểm người.
Chỉm năm năm năm năm, phần chăm tổng số bài thi đặt điểm đuối của cả kỳ thi.
Trong khi đỏ điểm, các bạn biết, đồng quân văn là chính phẩm em làm điểm và chỉ có tán thi xinh đặt mức điểm này.
Năm nay, không có thi xinh nào đặt điểm người.
Mức điểm chung mình môn văn của thi xinh cả nước là xói năm điểm.
Dạm nửa điểm sau với năm năm, khung chăm lắm.
Kỳ thi tốt niềm chung, phụ thông năm nay, sát trong hai ngày, mùa vào mẹ hai thần sau.
Và hôm một phẩy hai ngày chữ thi xinh đăng kỳ sự thi.
Tăng gần sống mẹ hai nghiên, sau với năm trước và là kỳ thi có quy môn lớn nhất từ trên đi này.
Thế quá kỳ thi đường sự dục đồng thời, nè sát công nhận tốt nghiệp chung hả vụ thông.
Và làm cân cứ xế tuyển đại học cao đăng.
Sau khi biết điểm thi xinh còn như cầu phúc khá đường nục đơn tại nguyên đăng kỳ sự thi.
Tương ngày 1 môn môn đến hết ngày 1 năm tham bài.
Công tắc phúc kháu sự kiến hoàn thành chạp nhất vào ngày 2 mời tham bài.
Tương ngày 1 mái tham bài thì xinh mất đầu đăng kỳ điều trình và bộ xung quyển vọng sẽ thuyền đáp câu đăng.
Chứ nghĩ thống của bộ giữa giúp đào tạo.
Thôi xanh đang kỳ kéo sài đến người bài giờ ngày 1 môn tham bài.